hello
how are you what's going on what's new
how's the family how's work
how's the country i'm dave rubin it's
november
6th 2020 we are three full days
post-election and we still don't have a
winner
we'll unpack that and more on today's
episode of the direct message
all right guys a lot to talk about uh
i'm not gonna bludgeon you with stats
today
i've been trying not to do that anyway
uh but i'm gonna try to analyze a little
bit of
what could possibly happen in the future
and we'll kind of go from there i'm
going to do a little bit
on on some media coverage and then i do
want to talk about one sign that that i
hope
most people would see as good either way
which is
that the gay vote did shift a lot
even if you're a lefty gay i hope that
you wouldn't want
gay people to only have to vote for one
party as if the entire gay community is
a monolith and must think
the same way although that's generally
how they think about these things
so we'll break down some of those
numbers i mentioned some other numbers
in the last couple days about how trump
did actually shockingly well within
the muslim community and the latino
community and we're seeing all sorts of
of interesting things that have maybe
changed the demographics
of the way the uh parties actually look
at who they have to go after and how
they have to go after them
but obviously all of that is secondary
to the fact that we don't know
who won the election uh in case you
forgot on tuesday night it was looking
really good for trump
and then at about 11 o'clock pacific
suddenly all the states that seemingly
were going
to trump suddenly stopped counting i
didn't know that stopping counting was a
thing i didn't know you can't count
late into the night but suddenly
everybody stopped counting
and then in the last you know 48 hours
or so we're seeing sort of recounts and
they're checking
ballots and in pennsylvania apparently
your ballot doesn't even have to be
postmarked by the date of the election
so it could have come in after the
election that seems a little weird
there's all these strange irregularities
and one of the strengths and weaknesses
of america is that we have states that
can all kind of do things their own way
and they've done things their own way
for decades and decades and decades
about
200 plus years of that and there are
strengths
in that we have a diverse country where
you can choose where to live and that
might be hopefully a little more in line
with the way you think and want to live
and you can be around people that you
like
strange that i'm here in los angeles but
nobody's perfect or
uh the counter to that of course is that
you'd have one giant
sort of machine on top of you and then
it would make a decision meaning the
federal layer would make some sort of
decision the king the president the
prime minister
and that everyone would have to obey
that i i don't view that as good
now the weakness part of that is all of
these states and we're seeing this right
now they have different rules when it
comes to how they count the ballots when
they count the ballots what they're
going to do
in many of the states that we're having
these odd recountings in they are
democratic governors and democratic
attorney generals that's just a fact
that doesn't mean they're corrupt that
doesn't mean they're evil but it is just
a fact
and as i've been talking about this
attorney general of pennsylvania
actually said days before the election
that biden was going to win the election
and now pennsylvania obviously is one of
the ones
where trump went from up 700 000 to now
i think he's down
a couple votes but again i don't want to
get lost in the numbers because that
will just make everybody crazy and by
the way you can really
feel the craziness going all over the
place um
before though i get into some of my my
predictions and i want to kind of lay
out what will happen
i think if if trump wins what will
happen if biden wins what will happen if
this really gets
strung out for a while and everything
else um i do want to mention one thing
about being here in los angeles during
this now i know a
ton of people here in los angeles that
secretly
voted for trump and as i've been saying
for weeks i didn't know anyone that was
a trump person
last time that voted for biden this time
and i hear so
many versions of that story from you
guys
literally across the country and yet
here we are
in these numbers that that we're
supposed to believe but okay that that's
just fine
uh one of the interesting things though
is that i went to my local supermarket
yesterday
and in the supermarket for the last
since lockdown
you know it's been kind of depressing in
there and they only let a certain amount
of people in and you got to wear your
mask and there's someone outside that
looks depressed
and one day i didn't have a mask and i
said i forgot my mask at home and i was
like oh can i just have a mask
i'm just you know i'm literally i'm like
picking up i was picking up coffee i
think
you know can i just get a mask from you
guys and the manager came
out and he was like if i give you a mask
i have to give everybody a mask
which is the same thing as remember when
you're in third grade and they're like
if you bring cupcakes for your birthday
you got to bring them for everybody you
can't just bring them for
the people you like anyway yada yada the
place has been kind of depressed they've
had their outdoor seating
pretty much all closed throughout this
there's been like two or three tables
it's been kind of quiet in there i'm not
even sure if they've been playing music
anyway i go yesterday and music is
blasting
all the employees you can just see like
everyone's happy the outdoor section
suddenly magically open again
like there's just some weird stuff now
they're all on the assumption
obviously that that biden is going to
win but if your
state of being your your very happiness
your existential like
world view has been so caught up in this
that you chose to be depressed
for however long and now magically even
though we don't even have a decision yet
you're you're
up and about and you're happy and you're
singing and everything else man
that is that is not a way to live and
that's why i always say you have to have
a wider
philosophical or religious view of the
world something
that is eternally true otherwise you
know your guy gets in you're depressed
the other guy gets in you're happy and
you'll basically end up
bipolar okay so now let's let's talk a
little bit
about where we're at and what's going on
so right now
it's still it's basically just a
complete cluster
of insanity that's kind of where we're
at we've got about six
seven states that still haven't been
decided most of them trump was leading
it now it's either getting closer
or biden has taken the lead arizona is
the reverse of that where
uh they had called it for biden now it's
looking towards trump but it doesn't
none of that stuff matters let's just
let's just put that aside because i
don't think they
all these states are going to make some
decisions today there's a feeling in the
mainstream media
and from the twitter audi that it's like
it could happen at any moment they're
just going to announce by it and it
wouldn't
i wouldn't put it past these people to
just announce biden and then have to go
from there and the biden campaign
released a statement today saying
something like if if trump doesn't leave
the white house
in 70 days you know we'll the law
enforcement will escort him out or
something
so that type of tweet's allowed on there
but you know not the other tweets okay
okay fine
um so let's let's do it this way so if
biden wins let's do
let's do biden winning first and kind of
kind of where we're at
oh by the way uh i do want to mention
that this morning
on the reuben report community i posted
you know sort of how i can help what do
you guys think i can do in the midst of
all this like at a micro level meaning
personally
at a macro level meaning sort of
societally like what what can we all do
not just me but what can we all do
individually
and we got hundreds of responses and
really interesting stuff and i'm trying
to respond to
as many people as possible in there so
again if you do want direct
communication with me
um especially because it's very obvious
that the twitter bans
and the suppression and all that stuff
like it's coming man it's coming and
that will lead me into the bite and
stuff in just a sec
uh so please do join us at
reubenreport.com because it's direct
communication with me
and it's sane and there's no trolls and
there's no bots and and it's all good
okay
so look if biden wins first i think what
we'll get
out of the media class and out of
the establishment class is basically ah
you see the four evil years
the four cancerous vile disgusting years
were
were now purged we've now purged them
and now we can return to some level of
normalcy now the good guys will be in
charge again now we will
be america again and we'll have will
have removed
that cancer and all that and i think
you'll you'll really see that messaging
and then i think what you'll also see is
what i've been warning about for the
last couple of weeks where we've seen
these tweets from
people like robert reich who was in the
uh robert reich
reich i suppose at some level uh who is
in the uh
clinton administration you know talking
about these truth and reconciliation
committees and we're going to need lists
of people like
i don't put it past any of the
establishment people to just really
start
coming up with lists and names and try
to just destroy
people and destroy anyone associated
with trump and everything else which in
many ways would be
the most anti-american thing you could
do and what i'm saying is
if trump actually stepped down stepped
away said i lost this thing biden comes
in
and then you still are going after them
you're going after all the people
remember
after for all the cries of locker up and
everything else
trump never did it he never did it and
we have to allow
for governments to have their run and
then
step away and we can't be just chasing
everybody and by the way once you break
that seal
and you start going after the people
before you uh well then of course what
you've welcomed is that someone will
come for you as well
um all right but if biden wins i think
first we're gonna that will be the main
messaging america is somehow
back the world likes us again we like
ourselves again
and then i think what you'll also see is
that coronavirus will slightly start
disappearing now that i think you can
argue this one either way because on one
hand biden was really ramping up the
fear around it and talking about you
know a national lockdown and everything
else but my
personal suspicion about corona is that
once the system gets what it wants
if it gets what it wants in a biden win
i think suddenly we're going to start
seeing that things start opening up
again and that states will start opening
up again and everything else and i don't
think it was a grand conspiracy
to say that the lockdowns especially in
the blue states had something to do with
trying to take out trump as much as
possible
so i think you can argue it either way
on one hand they've really ramped up the
fear and people seem to
like the lockdowns they like being
controlled and on the other hand it's
like oh but they accomplished their goal
we got by him
so now let's let's return um i think one
of the other things that i'm really
worried about if biden wins
is that big tech will now have nothing
to fear
so you can even see with this election
and you know last week
they had those silly uh senate hearings
with big tech and it was like all right
it's just theater i like you ted cruz
but it's just theater
because you're not going to do anything
before the election and then what
happened well
we're seeing tweets taken down left and
right i woke up this morning i had like
six emails from twitter about warnings
about my tweets
and that people were reporting them you
only get the report emailed to you if
like a high-level person
reports it because otherwise every
single one of my tweets is reported by a
bunch of
you know genderless anime avatar losers
um
so like they're they're clearly going to
make the move right like and this is
what you know when i make all my star
wars references one of the things i kept
saying was
well if biden gets in if the machine
starts taking over again and we've had
this battle
two-sided battle but now the machine
takes over biden
big tech the democrats protect well why
wouldn't you just shut down half of the
people you shut down the droid army
that's
that's the analogy that i've been using
here and in essence i think
that big tech at that point would just
begin the purge
like why why wouldn't they why would you
allow for all these bad people
who mainstream will call uh hitler and
racists and accomplices and all of these
things
so i think big tech will be emboldened
to do bad stuff
um but there will be there are there are
some reasons that maybe things could be
somewhat okay which is that the
republicans actually did pretty decently
down kick
ticket assuming they keep the senate
well then you know whatever this machine
is i don't think biden's in charge of it
the biden harris clinton obama
whatever this thing is it's going to
have you know some
bulwark against it which is a republican
senate but you know
i don't know can the republicans
actually stand up to anything without
trump or are they just like
a bunch of impotent losers i don't know
and again this is why i've never
considered myself a republican in all of
this right
like i absolutely supported trump
especially in the last couple weeks
because i thought he was the best
vehicle to just keep breaking this thing
so we could try to rebuild something
good
but i never have once said that i'm a
republican
because these guys are pretty
unimpressive as a as a group of people
do they have the better ideas in my view
than the democrats at this point well of
course they do but that doesn't mean
they do anything really
um so i think we'll have an emboldened
big tech we'll have
you know hopefully some level of
republican resistance
and and then i think what that then
leads to
is some interesting things uh you know
what i'm gonna move
uh michael i'm gonna move our third
story up to to now actually because
uh there were some demographic things
and then i'll get to what happens
uh if trump wins in just a sec but there
were some demographic things that were
super interesting
in the midst of all this so the lgbtq
vote it's a lot of letters i could have
thrown an i in there it's unclear to me
how the queue is different than the
other letters but that
lgbtq vote in 2016 for trump it was 13
and it more than doubled to 28 so trump
did pretty well
with the gays you know this guy that
they said hated the gays
even though when i met him that day he
was thrilled that we were there
and said he couldn't care less um so
he more than doubled with the gays black
men
went from 14 to 20 percent that's pretty
significant
right and black women actually doubled
from four to eight so of course the the
twenty percent of the eight percent it's
not that those are huge numbers
but it does show you that the
traditional
oh you cannot vote for a republican if
you're this
but that thing may be broke breaking
right now and and no matter what happens
to trump after this
i think you'd have to credit him for
that right well you don't have to do
anything right
they'll always figure out a way around
it but like i think that that
might be his greatest legacy um
especially if come 2022 if we have
you know two years of democratic rule
and they and biden brings back critical
race theory
and they bring back title ix and the
riots continue because the anarchists
and the riot
riot people whatever they are they don't
they don't like biden they don't like
the democrats but he'll just do nothing
about it
um and the states will do nothing about
it um
so i think there are promising signs in
that regard as i said before even the
muslim vote was very
high for trump considering uh you know
relative to years past
so there's there's good signs here
okay so that's that's if biden wins if
biden wins i think basically the forces
at least that
that i have been fighting against i
think they get emboldened but i think
there are some ways
that they don't go completely bananas
and perhaps
perhaps and i would love for this to
happen
perhaps those last sliver of good
liberals
actually feel kind of emboldened with
biden and then they actually do push
back
on the woke nonsense i don't see that
there's any evidence that that can
happen and the woke-ism just destroys
everything so
will harvard suddenly become a little
better now will the new york times
suddenly become a little bit better will
any of these people who run around
calling everybody racist become a little
bit better i don't think so
but i suppose there is a chance and i'm
trying to give you guys a little silver
lining today
um oh you know what i want to pull up
this tweet by
uh before we get to trump i want to pull
up this tweet by megyn kelly and i will
be interviewing megyn kelly later today
just to sort of break down the media
take on this whole thing because as i
always tell you guys i think the media
take on it
and the level at which we get
information is sort of more important at
some level
than the level of what actually is
happening it's only happening if we can
actually actually
if we can only actually get the
information um so megan let's throw this
tweet up she had an interesting tweet
she said pelosi says biden has a huge
mandate
really dems losing seats when supposed
to gain them in her chamber
dn gained control of senate saw dt
donald trump win more votes than ever
with minority groups and did not see the
promised blue wave
truth will prevail in january when
gridlock settles in
so the reason i thought that was
interesting was because pelosi's already
saying this is a huge mandate a huge
mandate
and it's like well the facts are that
it's not
really a huge mandate no matter what
happens no matter what happens
it's not a huge mandate um but let's
also
admit right nancy could you admit that
you guys never gave
trump a mandate for even one day right
you ran with russia collusion hoax the
entire time
which is so funny the same people who
ran with the russian collusion hoax that
led to a fake impeachment
a foe impeachment they're the ones that
saying right now no no
no there could be nothing wrong with our
election system right now the russians
somehow hacked it last time and trump
had something to do with it
right and we're going to run on that for
years and undermine all of the systems
but right now it's going our way so the
system is perfect the system is perfect
i'm seeing a ton
of hypocrisy on that one the same people
the system's evil it's corrupt it's
broken
it's russian influence now because
they're getting the results they want
dude best system ever best system ever
it's just incredible amazing
absolutely staggering okay so i thought
that was interesting and as i said i'll
be interviewing megan later today we'll
have some clips up tomorrow
uh the full will be on sunday and as
always it'll be early on the blaze and
on reubenreport.com
um okay so now let's talk about if trump
wins now first off we have to
lay out i suppose a scenario that trump
can win because the media is itching
to call this thing right now and the
states are trying to do everything they
can to make it happen
so trump winning so if biden wins
whatever that means meaning that the
state certified the media runs with it
that probably i suppose could happen in
the next couple days it seems like that
could happen in the next couple days
for trump to win i don't see how that
could happen in the next couple days
because it doesn't look like these
recounts are going to help him maybe the
arizona one does
now there's probably going to be a
recount altogether
in wisconsin so that delays things a
little bit depending on what happens
with the other states if fiden's not
able to get to the magic number um but a
trump win
realistically has to go through the
courts what that means is that there
will be enough contested
elections at the state level that the
courts will have to fight this out so
this would so think of this basically as
what happened in 2000 with george w bush
and with al gore
except that instead of it only happening
at one
state level and really at a local level
broward county
that it would be happening at a
multi-state level now i suspect
that trump still has a a card or two up
his sleeve
i i suspect that trump did think that
this could very possibly happen
uh there's a video of attorney general
bill barr from i think it's about two
months ago
uh being interviewed by wolf blitzer
saying how he felt that the amount of
massive fraud that could happen with
mail-in ballots is off the charts
and that they have to look into it and
all that so the idea that trump
didn't think oh man could the system
really come crashing down on me
and could they just sort of stop an
election and then cause chaos for a
couple days and everything i was like
and again whether you think all that is
true or not um
the beauty of the system of the courts
is now the courts
then can actually ascertain the
information right like trump doesn't own
the courts
um so if you if you hate trump then
still getting things to go to the courts
well i guess you don't like the courts
at this point either and he's appointed
some of the
core people and that's why everything's
just such a mess anyway but the path for
trump i think
only goes through the courts like i
don't see a way that pennsylvania is
going to come around and be like trump
won even if they
even if he actually did like i just
don't sort of see that happening now
georgia is finding all of these votes
and
georgia which was trump is now biden and
it's days later like it's just happening
everywhere in front of our eyes
okay i think i think trump if he fights
it in court well then we probably end up
in like two months of this craziness and
and that that's not a reason to stop
fighting
obviously um but i think it's dangerous
for just the health of the nation
overall you know what i mean like just
the endless fighting and you guys know
everything being equal
i want trump to win here right like i
think that would be the best
scenario to to keep america a free
democratic capitalist nation i still
believe that okay
um for whatever his flaws might be and
some of his over-the-top rhetoric
of the last couple days like you know
when trump goes out there and says well
i
absolutely won it's like well not really
that's not really what happened and he
that's what trump does right he goes
over the top and then kind of reels it
back in
um but unfortunately we don't have a
media that can deal with this stuff
honestly
so what i would sort of fear here is
that we end up in like just two more
months of this craziness and
i think there's pro i think there's
probably so many mental health issues
that we're not dealing with properly i
mean i think that's very clear if you
look at what the average blue check
person is doing on twitter
like there's a certain point where well
we're
all we'll all kind of snap we'll all
kind of snap i have no doubt
that you guys are having some problems
in your family related to politics
and with friends related to politics and
and i've got a couple of those
situations for as public as i am about
all of this at some
level you would think oh people know
know what i think and it's like it is
what it is
and then still in the last couple days
people have started coming out of the
woodwork and
and being all angry at me and i do
always find that the anger only goes one
way like
i'm not angry at my friends that voted
for biden or that didn't support trump
or whatever like
i think maybe they were mistaken i'm not
even sitting here telling you i'm
totally right about everything but like
the anger and i'm gonna remove you from
my family i'm not gonna be your friend
anymore i'm going to get you out of my
life that seems to be a one-way
anger and that i think there's
philosophical reasons for that that i
that i actually wrote about in my book i
mean i think if
if you just think this is everything if
you just look wake up in the world
every day and you just look around and
just think current events
are the answer to everything and that's
what you do oh that happened this
happened that happened this happened
this happened
and you never look up right you never
think about what the big picture is
what life really is all about well then
you can you'll be angry
at everyone all the time so trump's path
i think is through the courts it would
be a messy messy slog to get there
but i will say this trump is a fighter
in a way that
normal republicans aren't right like you
can even see it right now
these these lincoln project dingbats who
pumped like a hundred million
bucks into one of the senatorial races
and then they lost i think it was to
joni ernst it's like
well you guys they're all feeling
emboldened right now like they're
feeling emboldened they're like we're
gonna double down on everything keep
doing everything and it's like
you guys aren't even republicans like
what are you fighting for how are you
conservative or republican
if you're gonna put in people if you
will fight against your only fighters
right and then you're gonna actually put
in people
who are against everything that you
purport to believe in like you're not
you're not republicans or conservative
you're not even principal you're just
you're just people that
want to be liked i guess and that is a
thing that is a thing in the world
that people just sort of throw in the
towel and just say okay i just want to i
just want to be liked like that
that is a thing so anyway trump's trump
slog to get there
is is a long court battle i think the
biden thing they're probably going to
try to call this thing for biden in the
next couple days and then trump will
contest
and then we'll kind of see where we're
at and we'll and hopefully the violence
won't be too crazy you know
you know portland they've gone into some
residential neighborhoods and they're
yelling at people and
and burning [ __ ] down and you know we're
seeing this in new york city and some
other places hopefully some calmer heads
prevail
uh but i don't know i i genuinely don't
know
i think i think let me throw in one
other thing here
i've laid out the map for biden it
probably happens in the next couple days
the media runs with it
big tech gets prepared to like get rid
of all of the opposition
the real resistance actually like the
people who are against the system
they'll be the ones taken out right and
that that's that is a problem
um and i've laid out the the trump one
which is
that we go through the courts and we
just kind of see where we're at and then
and then even after the courts if they
actually said trump wins
can you imagine the insanity that that
the left would unleash
i mean i can't even possibly imagine you
can see how
how vindictive and angry they are right
now when they think they've won like
imagine if at the end of this they
actually lose
then then we got a bigger problem so
there's all of that and then there's
also well okay
if trump just says you know what maybe
he doesn't take it all the way maybe
suddenly he's like you know what
we did everything we could there's
there's nothing left we looked at all
the legal
uh repercussions we looked at all the
options there's absolutely nothing left
and he steps away well then what happens
to the republican party do you just
get this sort of neutered republican
thing that kind of wants to be liked by
the media never accomplished anything or
did he model enough on on how to fight
so you actually
get some good republicans now that was
my hope all along remember in the last
couple weeks i kept saying my hope is
if trump wins again you get that
beautiful thing out of the republicans
in 2024 and you get this really wide
swath
of people that include nikki haley and
dan crenshaw and maybe candace owens and
tim scott and
who the hell knows who the hell knows i
think that that's a little more
difficult to argue if if he just steps
away
anyway it's the weekend guys i'm having
friends over tonight we're gonna drink
maybe we'll smoke a little something
because i think we're free for now who
the hell knows
i hope you have a great weekend try not
to spend too much time online although
as i said
megyn kelly clips tomorrow and full
video on sunday but get out there
find the ones you love have some fun do
something you like to do
whatever that is walk the dog play some
video games do a little
yoga take her take a jog whatever it is
get out there it's it's going to be okay
it's going to be okay i promise you
and if it isn't going to be okay we may
as well think it's going to be okay
because
the alternative is pretty freaking
depressing all right have a good weekend
everybody
you